you know what I jumped about on this day
I was like one day I will be on that
show after five times finally made it
Mercedes diamonds have you had to sum up
your drag race experience in just a
couple of words what would you say what
you see on TV is not just their doing in
real life so it's a lot of work people
think like oh yeah
God watch YouTube and I know how to do
this and that and no girl it's not like
that you got to do it this is a real so
it's not like Oh YouTube things it's
real and it's a lot of working it can
feel a bit stressful sometimes but just
don't get over your head like this get
out of your head and do the work what
you hope The fans walk away thinking of
Mercedes hopefully they will say wow you
know what every Muslim president is not
a terrorist because I was on the watch
list for so many years and I had to
change my full name to get out of the
watch list so I can apply it couldn't go
nowhere so there's other reason why I
wanted to come on this show and just
feel like you know what it's okay to be
who you are you know people look at
mostly people as a terrorist they
combined as one one person did something
and they're like yep the whole religions
are terrorists so but hopefully they
will think that way they're like wow is
they're not all the same what does it
mean to you to be the first Muslim Queen
and to bring that to the show is a
blessing that I am coming on and I am so
grateful for it and I want to speak for
other people that are that doesn't have
a voice that are scared to be who they
are and it's okay to be who you are and
still believe in your religion because
I'd ended the day honey you got to be
happy and I'll follow your heart and
leave your religion
well you followed your heart to drag
race I sure do you know you can still
believe in your religion and follow your
heart if they're happy you got to be
happy too so that's what I want to tell
to other people that it's okay to be you
and I still believe in your religion
this seems like a very sisterly group
did you walk away with friends for life
this caste in my eyes yeah all of the
girls are my sisters and I do
communicate with them actually go with
talk and just reach out to them like hey
girl how are you hope you have a good
weekend even we don't talk a lot I've
just send them a text message I just
check on them and see how they're doing
who do you talk to the most Aereo sergio
plastique de Angie and the neuroses I
talk to I check on them
[Music]